[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Google Cloud's
Anthos helps support companies
in modernizing their services
in hybrid and multi-cloud
environments.
But what does the stack
actually look like, and what
use cases does it solve?
Join us as we talk to Arctiq
about how they implemented
a hybrid cloud environment on
this episode of "Stack Chat."
Thanks so much for
joining us, Kyle.
Tell us a little bit more
about what Arctiq does.
KYLE BASSETT: Yeah,
thanks for having us.
Arctiq is focused on services,
and we're born in cloud,
and focusing on
helping developers
using Git code in production,
and all the things that
go around that.
And most of the time, we're
spending that with enterprises,
so helping them solve
that culture condition
problem of moving from
their old world to cloud.
And all this automation and
everything that comes with it--
we're helping enable them and
getting them to be successful.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
tell us a little bit more
about the specific
infrastructure.
KYLE BASSETT: Yeah, so
this particular customer
we worked with, they have
a traditional application.
They've made it a microservices.
It's cloud native.
It runs in GCP and GKE.
And it's very
successful in that,
but they've got
customers that have
challenges around locality, data
residency, things like that.
So they may have to
deploy in a region
where there isn't a Google Cloud
or they don't have good network
connectivity.
So for them, they've
had to manage
that in the past of deploying
homegrown Kubernetes
environments in those places
and trying to manage them,
and trying to keep them
updated, and patched.
And it's a tough job to be
able to manage these things.
So they were looking for a
common experience and a way
to take all the automation and
all the good things they've
done in cloud, and
be able to apply that
into their on-prem offering.
And most importantly, offer
a consistent experience that
is easy to support,
and then the customer
is not getting a lackluster
experience just because it's
not in cloud anymore.
So that's really what's
given them the agility
to be able to do this.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: OK.
So if they've got their
home base in the cloud,
but then they've got all
these different customers
in different places, and there's
no commonality between some
of those environments,
then, as you said,
it's a pretty difficult
thing to manage.
I hear that Anthos kind of
played a big part in helping
standardize this environment.
So what does that
actually look like?
KYLE BASSETT: Yeah.
So this customer was
leveraging homegrown Kubernetes
in many cases, and when they
saw Anthos, their interest was,
could we take Anthos and
that reference architecture,
apply it into our
customer scenarios,
but leverage our exact
same CI/CD pipeline,
all our same Helm
templates, all those charts
that we've been leveraging
and deploy on there
without having to replatform
all their deployment every time?
So they looked at that
as a real game-changer
for them, to be able to
go to market and solve
some of these
customer challenges
that they hadn't been
able to solve yet.
So we started the project
and built the architecture
around this.
We deployed a VMware
cluster in Berlin
and got that up and running.
And then it was taking all
the lessons learned in cloud.
So they were using Cloud Build.
They were using GCR.
They were using a lot of
those rapid cloud tools.
So really, all we had to do
is get those artifacts now
into their private stack, and be
able to deploy against Anthos.
So within a couple of weeks, we
were able to stand all this up,
put it through
performance testing.
It was a real lesson learned.
And the biggest impact was, can
we take this common experience
and make this on-prem
deployment look just
like another deployment region?
That was the real goal.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right.
So now, they've got all
of these environments that
are kind of like offshoots
of their core environment,
but they all look
pretty much the same.
And then they roll out
the code the same way
they were kind of
rolling it out before,
but now it's easy to roll
it out to all of those.
KYLE BASSETT: Yeah.
It really is that perfect
hybrid story because that's
the deployment region,
is the end-state code
after it's tested.
That's where it's going to run.
But they still have to do
innovation and testing,
and put new features in.
So that's where the cloud
comes in handy for them.
So they were able to spin
up clusters on demand,
and we started looking at things
like config management for them
and helping them Gitify
all that workflow.
But they can spin up
clusters on demand in GKE,
do all their testing,
tear it back down.
Once they get a release ready,
they can push that release out
to that on-prem environment,
and it's all just
through standard
automation framework.
So it takes away the whole
worrying about a maintenance
window, or doing it on Sunday.
They can roll out changes and
be really rapid and really agile
in their development cycle.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
even though they've
kind of made all the
other environments
common to their
home environment,
how do they keep them in sync?
KYLE BASSETT: Well,
keeping them in sync,
one of the big things
we've been looking at
is doing everything through
policy, so policy management.
And that's one of
the things config
management, part
of Anthos, brings
to the table is instead of
people going in and making
manual changes to
clusters, why isn't
it done through a Git workflow,
or PR process and a peer
review?
And when that gets approved,
it gets pushed out.
And not just to one cluster.
You can do that
to many clusters.
You can also do it to
clusters on-prem or in cloud.
The other piece it
gives them is they
can add extra things that
they're concerned about,
like security frameworks, or
if they're doing custom Istio
rule sets, their developers--
they can start to make sure
that that framework is spread
across all the environments.
And then that steps up the
audit capability, the compliance
side.
So when someone
comes in and says,
how are you managing
these things?
They're able to build
a report and say,
this is all driven from source.
Look at the Git
log, and that's how
we manage our infrastructure.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And it's all the same
across all those environments
because the unified config
management makes it
easy to roll out.
KYLE BASSETT: Yeah, even
down to if someone jumps on
with an elevated
access and makes
a manual change to a cluster,
that drift that usually
happens?
Config Manager will
change it back.
But if you put time into
building the policies, and then
developers can focus
on writing code,
and the security teams
can focus on making sure
that that code is
of the quality.
So if everyone puts
time into this,
it just comes
through a pipeline,
and it all drives the quality.
And people in
various departments,
and most importantly,
developers can
focus on developing and
releasing at a high velocity.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And their customers
just get to focus on using
the same stable application
that now they feel more
confident in because the parent
company kind of has that
responsibility of making
sure it works everywhere.
KYLE BASSETT: Yeah.
In the end, the
customer just wants
to be able to do their job, and
they're buying the software.
And they want to know that
they have the trust that it's
going to be up,
because a lot of these
are billing-based application.
It's like the revenue-generating
side of the business.
So they're looking at
it as a managed service,
but they've got constraints
that they have to be on-prem.
But they need to know that when
new packages or new updates
come, they don't have
that worry that they're
going to have to go through
a lot of pain or an outage
to their customer, which
isn't good, obviously.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So as you were
kind of helping them roll out
this entire architecture,
what would you
say kind of the biggest hurdle
that you jumped over was?
KYLE BASSETT: I would
say just standardizing
all the configuration.
This particular
customer spent a lot
of time putting the work in.
And knowing that they
could do it manually
to get it working
once, they actually
put the time into
automating it all
and testing it,
which really pays off
in folds as you start to scale.
So that was one
of the challenges
we took is just getting that
exact workflow they were
using in cloud and
applying it and finding
the pipeline for on-prem.
Obviously there were some
security restrictions
around networking and access.
We had to deploy
an on-prem registry
and find a way to sync
all the images down
so we have that workflow.
So the biggest thing
is they put the time in
and we worked with
them to enhance it,
and then now they're paying off
in folds as they roll this out.
As they move forward to push
this and scale their business,
they don't have a lot
of technical debt.
It's all documentation
is living.
It's all in the Git repo.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thanks so much
for coming in and showing us
how you actually kind of
built this architecture
with this customer to support
all of their own customers.
KYLE BASSETT: Yeah, so
thanks for having us.
We're really looking forward
to rolling out Anthos
to more customers and
getting it out in the market.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Get
Anthos ready by checking out
this quick lab on
modernizing and deploying
your application with GKE.
Thanks for watching, and
make sure to subscribe
for more great Google
Cloud Platform content.
We'll see you next
time on "Stack Chat."
[MUSIC PLAYING]